is the brain able to improve mental
health is it having an effect on things
like dementia sleep and particularly
dream sleep seems to provide a form of
almost overnight therapy where it will
take difficult painful
experiences and it will essentially act
almost like a nocturnal soothing bomb
and just take the sharp edges off those
painful experiences so that you come
back the next day and you don't feel as
bad they don't feel as as painful
anymore and so it's not time that heals
all wounds but it's time during sleep
and specifically dream sleep there is
this pulsing sewage system it's called
the glymphatic system and it only kicks
into high gear during deep sleep and it
it sort of washes out all of the
metabolic detritus of the day